so really it's trying to use the
insights from neuroscience to better
accomplish the classic goals of
marketing and so part of that is
understanding the general principles
about the brain and how the brain takes
some information of the brain learned
brain has experiences remembers makes
decisions and how to utilize the general
principles which navigate that space to
better accomplish marketing goals and
then secondly it's really about trying
to collect as much no scientific data as
possible to address very specific
marketing questions so if you're
comparing which trailer to use if your
your marketing for a a movie for example
you can do a classic consumer group
would you ask people there's lots of
evidence showing that people's explicit
responses are very different from what
the brain says and what they will do
later on and a much better cue for that
can be a direct measure of actual neural
responses so that's so the other half of
neuro marketing is actually collecting
raw neuro scientific data
gentlemen welcome to the show how ie
very good indeed this book this
blindsight that i have in my hands is
one of the coolest things that I've read
in absolutely ages I get sent tons and
tons of books and this is like softcore
porn to me and also to the listeners
today I'm sure as well fans of Richard
shot and Rory Sutherland and some of the
other fantastic guests that we've had on
today I think you should have your
notepads out because this is gonna be a
real special one so first off chance
Congrats on the book really good thank
you so much appreciate that how long
were you working on it two and a half
two and a half years roughly I mean it's
still not out yet so I would say we
could even stretch it to three we were
working on for a long time I think how
the book came about is that is an
interesting story as well tell us I
don't know Matt tell your side that his
is really funny yeah I mean so so I mean
the book really is is the melding of
these two worlds right so I come from
academic neuroscience my first I was in
I graduated from 25th grade when I
stopped being in school finally I spent
most of my lives and in labs and
libraries now it's really just driven by
a curiosity everything you want to
understand how the brain works why we do
the things we do what's what it makes us
tick and it was really just driven by a
pure curiosity really irrespective of
any sort of application and and for me
that moment was was really distilled
when I finished my PhD thesis what you
do is you have your your actual physical
thesis it's a bounded document about it
look it's it's fatik sort of pages and
there's a specific library with all the
PhD theses go and when I finished my PhD
thesis you're giving about a book and
you put a library I put a $50 bill in
that thesis and I guarantee you that
money is still there what was the title
geez the planet was the neuro basis of
language learning in autism
investigations with behavioral and
neural imaging studies yeah I mean of
I've heard of sexier thesis titles so
that you know that was Matt's journey
right so while he was in labs and
libraries like you put it I graduated
and I was fortunate enough to try to
start and fail at my own first company
while in my undergrad and after that I
was the first marketer brought on to a
startup so I was the other way around I
was what I would call a pop psych nerd
right so I would read a lot of pop
psychology books from back in the day
wisdom of crowds Thinking Fast and Slow
all those books are we now you know but
there's still pops I did not research
and I was lucky enough to be at a
leadership position early on record test
all that stuff so I read about neural
coupling and I would go change my my my
website and test neural coupling right
so having done that early on I tried to
read some of these researches that Matt
and other people like Matt wrote and
there's only so much my brain can do
after a while I'm like you know I simply
don't possess I'm immortal and there's
only so many abstracts you can read
before you're just as a marketer you're
like just give me just give me the gist
of it so I do I need to do yeah exactly
exactly and yeah I applied it to my own
life self dev you know I I grew a lot
out of it because it's psychology it
applies to so many things so after for
doing that for about 10 12 years
coincidentally Matt and I met and we
started teaching at Hope International
University he was the assistant dean and
I was a professor brought on and we
started to teach neuro marketing class
together and the class turned into an
idea for a textbook and then we decided
we don't want to write a textbook just
for marketing to write this book for
consumers and the last piece about me is
I am a consumer like everyone else
listening like you Chris like Matt I
like buying cool things and and and
using them and making them part of my
life but recently there's like this
weird divided between marketers and
consumers so a lot of this book is
written for consumer so they can
understand what happens when marketing
and brain mix sometimes intentionally
sometimes unintentionally because I
think we can have better products and
enjoy them guilt-free as consumers and
as marketers so it's just we're just not
there yet
is worried level of distress I'm hoping
this book is sort of one way of doing
that on top of combining Matt's lab
knowledge and my marketing application
knowledge and hopefully hopefully you
got a bit of that when you read the book
absolutely yet definitely did so new ro
marketing that's the that's the term
neuroscience meets marketing right cool
so how the brain works and then how you
can apply that to effectively market
products within the marketplace yeah so
really it's trying to use lies the
insights from neuroscience to better
accomplish the classic goals of
marketing and so part of that is
understanding the general principles
about the brain and how the brain take
some information of the brain learns the
brain has experiences remembers makes
decisions and how to utilize the general
principles which navigate that space to
better accomplish marketing goals and
then secondly it's really about trying
to collect as much no scientific data as
possible to address very specific
marketing questions so if you're you're
comparing which trailer to use if you're
you're marketing for a a movie for
example you can do a classic sort of
consumer group when you ask people
there's lots of evidence showing that
people's explicit responses are very
different from what the brain says and
what they will do later on and a much
better cute but that can be a direct
measure back to neural responses so
that's so the other half of neuro
marketing is actually collecting raw
neuro scientific data and curse I think
you like the story just to piggyback off
of what mat2 said but perfect this is a
real-life example
Cheetos that did a commercial and they
put it in focus groups and this is the
marketing aspect right you put all these
people in focus groups you make them
watch the commercial and you ask hey
what do you think of the commercial did
you like it did you not like it and they
ask you all these qualitative questions
in this case the commercial was
considered to mean flat-out way too mean
and then they hired on a different firm
who put people in fMRI functional
magnetic resonance imaging machines put
them in there ask the same questions and
when they were asked the questions in
the machine a part of the brain the
nucleus accumbens which is your pleasure
center lit up but when they ask their
questions outside of the machine similar
response
who me so what was originally going to
be a reason to no longer publish the
commercials that went ahead and did it
anyways and they were a hit
so you can go YouTube these right now
they're the the the underground Cheetos
commercials we're like well this lady is
doing her laundry in a laundromat and
this other lady guy just took takeout
takes all of her clothes out and dumps
him right she goes other people are
waiting for the laundry too and after
that the chester the cheeto comes in she
goes those are her whites you know what
to do and then she grabs a cheetah
throws it in and ruins her whites and
it's like that you can see you know in
the poorest group it's like it's to me
either
either us as people in the focus group
I'm ready to admit to ourselves that we
enjoy a little bit of mayhem or we
genuinely don't but part of your brain
brain doesn't lie
right and if you can look into the brain
you can be able to see that pleasure is
going off so they went ahead with it and
they got massive adoption this is before
the days of virality on YouTube and
Instagram yeah but no no that's a
perfect example of how what's marketing
versus what's neuromarketing how I can
get just cool insights out of that
amazing example of that is what happened
with the exit polls in Trump's election
versus the actual numbers you know like
that was more that was obviously more
cognizant people were aware of the fact
that they were lying it wasn't as if
their brain had voted one way and they
came out and bought in and voted another
way yeah exactly it was just like a
shock thing in their hand slipped or
something so yeah let's get into the
meat of it um what does eating the menu
mean Mac can I start and then you can
you can go and get eating the menu was
going to be the original title of the
book we loved it so much because we
loved Alan Watts there's two things Matt
and I love no matter what it's Kanye and
Alan Watts musicians don't roast us for
that and Alan Watts has this amazing
quote we don't just eat the food we eat
the menu and we open the book with
mental models and and Matt will go go
ham I'm telling you about mental models
but essentially you're well before you
even put that first bite of spaghetti in
your mouth all these other things have
had a massive impact on actually
impacting the taste of the food and that
was for us a great way to open the book
obviously the change in title but yeah
I'm Matt tell us tell us about mental
models yes I think this for me is one of
the most interesting things about
consumer neuroscience generally is
really this observation that we've known
in perceptual neuroscience for decades
now which is that we don't experience
the world directly we don't really take
in objective reality in we take in our
brains mental model so we're taking in
information with the through our eyes or
ears for our senses and and what we
ultimately perceive in terms of our own
internal subjective experiences our
brains best guess at what all of these
senses are combining to really conjure
up in terms of our own internal
experience so we don't experience
reality directly we experience our
brains mental model for business this
fundamental gap between our own
subjectivity and objectivity you talked
about this book this gap really makes
marketing magical we just experienced
the world the way it objectively is
we're rational creatures we go about and
we're just picking in reality
objectively and there's no need for cool
brands and and really interesting ways
of storytelling and marketing this gap
really is the opportunity for marketers
to create our reality and and we see
some really really interesting examples
of that especially within food which was
one of the reasons why we wanted to name
the book is because it really does
fundamentally shape our our music youry
experience yeah I couldn't agree more
there's a wonderful passage in the book
that I'm gonna read now for the people
that are listening and this is about
mental models remembering that the two
mental models episodes I've done with
George McGill are the first and second
best played ever on modern wisdom and
yet what we the the description we use
of mental models was from much more of a
self-development way what George said
was if you think of your brain as an
iPhone then mental models are the apps
that you plug into the OS to give you
different bits of functionality so that
was from a thinking tools perspective
but your approach for mental models also
makes sense the quote is our brains
don't experience reality directly
instead they construct a model of it
which neuroscientists call a mental
model our brains are constantly modeling
each time you take a bite of food you
aren't experiencing the food per se
your brains best guess at what the
experience of eating that food should be
like the sensation that the tongue
contributes this model but many other
things can to mental models are
incredibly impressionable and can be
influenced by numerous factors they're
all so hard if not impossible to correct
because we can never compare them to
reality and see where they've gone wrong
or we can ever experience is the mental
model itself so when a brand or business
influences our mental models they are
directly influencing our experience of
reality that is so scary that is
terrifyingly scary it's cool as hell
but it's so scary as well to realize
that the way the waiter shakes your hand
the smell of the restaurant when you
walk in the fact that the silverware is
in this particular way the jingle that's
someone you you know the classical
condition everything is in a very real
sense actually changing your reality
it's like a matrix [ __ ] man Chris Chris
you're like you're like in our brains
our original intro for the book was all
written around the matrix scene and then
we realized we're to head we realize not
everyone is in the matrix so we decided
to ironically unplug that no you're
absolutely right it really is and you
know part of it is gonna creep the crap
out of you lights going to creep you out
and then after a while you come to
realize that okay you walk into an Apple
Store you think yes of course it's an
Apple Store it's a really well-designed
store they thought about the layout and
the reducing friction done sure but then
you look at it from the perspective of
mental models man before you even look
at the first product the fact that
you're walking in it's already impacting
your sense of Apple right so you are
already getting your brains getting data
points right immediately as you walk in
so in some ways creating that experience
for you actually adds to your pleasure
of said products right just like it's
not as obvious as taste that's what we
use the concept of taste early on
because the taste our tastes are so
easily impressionable
but brands are creating this for us and
sometimes it creeps you out because
think it's manipulation and sometimes it
actually genuinely adds value to your
mental model of whatever is being sold
right there's the example of you know
there's a test that took a bunch of
golfers and have them go smack some call
golf balls around and one group got the
golf got the Alma said rackets as you
can see how a table golf clubs with with
the Nike logo and one without and of
course the Nike logo hit further so
whatever they mental model was actually
had a physical impact a subjective
aspect had an objective impact on
performance and it was I say the same
Golf Club just one had a night take on
exactly can you tell us the dock the the
pate and dog food study oh yeah one of
the reasons why we we focused on this in
the first chapter is that it really
allows you to see just how deep this
mental modeling goes because as Prince
mentioned our tastes are very very
impressionable vision is by strong are
by far our strongest days on the other
side of the spectrum tastes are our new
Satori sensations really our weakest and
so they did this interesting study a few
years ago where they had four types of
really really really fancy pate but he
had duck pate they had whose pet say
they had they got these things from the
distributors which actually supply
Michelin star restaurants in Manhattan
and then for the fifth dish they had dog
food and the actual dishes were prepared
identically so you put it in a blender
and you make it a really really nice
visual consistency you put a nice little
garnish with some crackers you serve it
on a really really nice plate you have a
waiter come by with with a white glove
and serve it to you and then speak in a
sophisticated accent and they told
people all right four of these are
really really really delicious pate the
other fifth one not going to tell you
which one but that's dog food can you
guess which one's dog food and nobody
could it was exactly synonymous with the
taste of these really really fancy
Michelin star rated duck pate and and
goose pate it's really the power of the
visuals and the power of all of these
extra gustatory forces which would
shaped our reality to such an extent
what we can't you can't tell the
difference between actual the taste of
dog food and something you'd pay $65 for
at Thomas Keller's restaurant in New
York I mean I wouldn't be having any of
the pattex I think pates pate is just
shite food it's just baby it's baby food
reconstitute baby food so some people
might be thinking well that sounds all
well and good but pates pate and you've
just got some schmoes off the street but
it was a similar study done with
sommelier x' as well right and that one
was add it ratcheted up the difficulty
ratcheted up a little bit
absolutely yeah so for whatever reason
is just such a fun testing ground for
neuro marketers it's because I'll lift
watts but that's why it's because it's
full of knobs you've got an fMRI that
categorically say is that wine is four
knobs yeah yeah so there's all these new
studies even without the fMRI they'll
say if I just give you this bottle of
wine and I've taken the actual label off
and I put a fake label on that says it's
from a really really fancy winery in
France or it has a lot of syllables
you'll actually taste the same wine and
report enjoying it more if you one
I think it's expensive so it's the same
exact wine and you you tell somebody's
expensive versus cheap same exact points
exact actual sensation happening at the
tongue you actually experience the more
expensive one better you report the life
is better you want it more often more
syllables on the label
same exact wine but you enjoyed that
more if you're told it's from Northern
California and not northern Dakota then
you actually experience its to be more
pleasurable all of these crazy factors
that I've nothing to do with taste
actually do influence people's direct
mental models of the wine and I think
the real knockdown experiment there that
you mentioned is done actually with
sommelier is who if anybody can tell the
difference between a real wine and and a
fake one this is you know
all of the you know the noobs that are
just you know drinking wine and two buck
chuck and all the 22 year olds partying
with just ready to get drunk off wine
the sommelier should be a step above
them but studies show that they actually
are prone to the same effects I know the
study actually done in France where they
took white wine and red wine and the
white wine they actually just put some
red food coloring into it and they gave
it to some yes and when some against
people that professionally trained that
get paid a six-figure salary for being
wine experts when they tasted this white
wine with red food coloring they
actually reported that it had taste like
berries and kind of a current flavor and
nothing all things that were in line
with the color of the line but had
nothing to do with the actual taste that
was hitting their tongues so yeah I
meant two models these things run very
very very deep and even the best of us
the sommelier czar so prone to them yeah
I mean the there's a cool Netflix
documentary I think it might be called
like Psalms or something and I have you
seen that Matt yeah really is so bad I
don't even know if it's still on Netflix
if it go and have a little search the
people listening at home go and have a
check out it's really cool like the
training that those guys go through is
Ruth it's like a it's like the Tour de
France but for wine and they're like I
know it's from there the northern slopes
of the the like Milan province in Spain
or whatever whatever like so the fact
that they've the fact they've been able
to be fooled it's pretty impressed I I
can I can say from firsthand experience
as I am such a knob I study dubious mark
the best part no Matt was waiting he's
like slowly put in it and somme somme is
a great documentary whether whether you
believe in small years or not shout out
to my buddy Ron Bonifacio who started
the restaurant that's in some quite a
bit but to go back to what we were
saying look you're right wine is a great
place to study this because in my my
opinion you got to get a base level
deliciousness for wine and after that
it's the subjective experience right um
but now at college we did that we brown
bagged wine as broke college students
and then we drank them so we could not
tell which grape it was and yes of
course lo and behold over time we're
able to tell right but I am not at the
level as at the documentary that you're
talking I can't tell you that it's from
the north northern part of Italy vintage
2001 not 2000 because those year the
grapes were absolutely yes no but to go
to bring back to you no I'm not I don't
discriminate I like all my libations
equally for beer though if you've gone
to a proper beer bar you buy a pilsner
what kind of glass does it come in tall
one tall pilsner glass like the tall
skinny slender Posner glass yeah you buy
a Belgian what kind of glasses are
coming it comes in a Belgian snifter
right and then you you know whatever
that might be so whether we you know
it's kind of fun to play tribalism right
now right beer versus wine drinkers but
ultimately beer drinkers you go to a
beer bar that actually gives you proper
glass based on the beer you're buying
that is 100% influencing your mental
model of that beer before you have them
to ever take your first step Pilsner
glasses for pilsners snifters for
whatever they might be for for quads and
whatever beers you want to get into
that's one hundred percent that and then
you know and we haven't even gotten into
again we're not tasting the beer we're
tasting the menu or in this case the
glass before we actually put the beer in
our face it's crazy I love it not so now
my knobs are not limited to wine I have
a number of friends that are knobs you
only drink beer so yeah it crosses it
crosses all all the alcoholic drinks so
next thing
how do brands use anchors to get our
attention
oh that's great Matt you want to explain
the foundation of anchors and then I can
I can give I can give some examples yeah
definitely so one key to this mental
modeling process is we can't experience
words objectively as we talked about it
so we always look for some sort of
reference point yeah deal with all these
these sort of nebulous signals coming to
us we need some sort of reference point
to be able to anchor our
you're standing so you you there's been
interesting studies done with this was
back to time and diversity back in the
late 80s where they'll have people spin
a wheel well spin a wheel it's a
perfectly random process and they'll ask
them these really really really
difficult questions which they have no
idea about so ask them well how many
African countries are in the United
Nations
how many Grammys did somebody of New
Zealand descent win you know all these
random questions they have no idea and
what was interesting is this random
wheel that just brought up a random
number
this actually influenced their
estimation so they spun this wheel and
it was Brendan was trying to guarantee
rhythm and it came up as 70 they would
guess well 70% of African nations are in
the EU or if they they spun the wheel
and it's three I said well you know
three New Zealanders probably you know
came to the Grammys and it was perfectly
random before and it was transparently
the most random process possible but
these served as anchors you have this
this this this really really a nebulous
problem space we don't have anything to
hold on to when you seek some sort of
reference point to understand this so
this influences our our judgment and
decision-making especially an
uncertainty that really influences our
attention as well this is something that
that brands use really in in clever ways
yeah and I'll give you some examples of
how they use them so I'll give you I'll
give you one that's really easy for all
of us to get and you'll will still fall
for it MSRP right you walk into a store
there's an MSRP and it's crossed out and
for some reason that's anchored your
value your perception of the value of
that product the I tell the story
quickly not a number box I didn't want
to go into the brand aspect of it - this
is more pricing and marketing strategy
behind pricing JCPenney one of the
largest and one of the oldest department
stores in the states they over 98
percent of their revenue came from sale
items what does that tell you
translation [ __ ] is always on sale right
right seriously so you walk into JC
Penney's they always have a sale going
on and JC Penney wanted to change things
up they brought on the the head of
retail for Apple came on and I have so
much respect for this dude
because he said we're no longer going to
going to practice vanity pricing let's
get rid of the the fake MSRP and let's
drop the pricing even beyond that so
consumers objectively are getting a
better deal and much more transparent
way to communicate what do you think
happened the first quarter that they did
that salesman sale hang yeah yeah yeah
so after two quarters of trying it they
went back to the old way of doing it and
guess what happened they'll run back up
but you love our anchors okay our brains
are like sailboats we're constantly
looking for places to anchor right so
when we the less we know the more we're
perceptible to anchoring so that's one
the other one is I mean that can go into
it a little bit more but I want to kind
of tease this anchoring is also how
attention works to grab your attention I
have to anchor something against what I
have to pick something that goes against
the anchor I have to Zig when everything
else is acting right so you walk up to a
refrigerator packed full of water
bottles and you're thirsty and you're
you don't care if it's a dollar or five
dollars to buy this water bottle you
just want to pick a water bottle and
you're a brand agnostic guess where
you're gonna go your attentions gonna go
towards the anchor the visual anchor is
established by all these similar looking
plastic crappy bottles and you see one
bottle in a cardboard box that's gonna
drive your attention if that's not there
then the boss watermaid looks basically
looks like a cologne bottle right that's
gonna grab your attention although we
didn't say attention but anchoring does
blow into attention and that's one of
the things where I think this is a good
point because of course we haven't
really jumped into b.e right and I know
your audience loves b/e matt and i love
b ii b ii has been sort of the crack
that gets us into this neural marketing
psyche biases and heuristics that world
that you get pulled into whether it's
for self help for me it was marketing so
i think i think this would be a good
point Matt to talk about how we Matt Mel
love me okay we have been convinced at
just how freakishly irrational humans
are Matt knows it way more pursue than I
do because he's a frickin neuroscientist
and I've seen it and now I've read all
the books we all have to NR ele I want
to meet him and give him a hug when I
see him because it's worldly I totally
changed up how
about life not just marketing so
neuromarketing to go back to your
initial question right yes it's
neuroscience and marketing but not and I
CBE as a very important branch to a
field of this stuff right b'e is a study
of irrationality and they've already
proven many times over we are super
irrational we like that we like that
that's raising the conversation about
what's happening to your brain in the
real world Matt and I love it we want to
take this momentum and go talk about all
the other things now that you're into
b.e let's let's explore where this go
you know that's the proverbial rabbit
hole right let's see there's much more
to this than irrationality and we want
to break that down only one of the
chapters in the book in our book is
really about ve the rest of the chapters
are stuff that we're hopefully hoping
goes beyond me right so if you love the
e I think you'll love the book but you
also go okay one or two chapters touch
on B and then they move on and even
anchors anchors are classic ve we take
anchors and then we use anchors should
truly get you to understand the
psychology of attention so we can get
into that if you want you want if when I
learned a little bit more about
attention again it throws something else
much yeah so one thing in terms of our
attention is that it's fundamentally
driven by novelty it's fun really driven
by new things so we tend to habituate to
constants constants aren't super
important to us from an evolutionary
standpoint if something's bidden fair
and and hasn't changed and hasn't hurt
us for a while we're gonna tend to sort
of ignore it's gonna float into the
background and so there's this process
where new things become the background
this is this process of habituation it's
something with our it's a fact of our
attention that we perceive the world and
taking information and attend to it
consciously and it's also and we'll
probably talk about this little bit
later it's also how we perceive our own
pleasure and then her own happiness is
is navigated by this as well so what's
interesting is in in the consumer world
there's all these constants you you have
items which were new at some points
everybody poppies in it becomes sort of
the new background since you want to
give you an example of the
and automotive industry yeah so when I
say imagine a sports car
what colors come to your mind red red
right it was even be red or yellow right
when Nissan about 15 years ago
relaunched their their Z their Zed
excuse me Chris their 350z it was this
crazy burnt orange color right that's
how you stand out I'll give you an
example from a smart car nor say these
own smart car and they did a billboard
where billboards are nice and square at
90 degrees you drive past a freeway 90
90 90 and then they had one that was
crooked and immediately you're boring
commute to traffic your anchor is set to
perfectly aligned billboards is one
that's crooked you immediately grabs
your attention and you know I mean we
can give marketing examples all day but
let's take a pause for how this
anchoring thing plays out in something I
would argue a universal language humor
right that that that that misdirection
that leads to a punchline that part of
humor man Matt and I really big fans of
Anthony Jeselnik we only talked about it
a little bit in the book because his
jokes are always way too inappropriate I
was laughing my when I was reading those
so I don't know it's okay if you don't
want to say it but it's my show I'm
gonna say whatever the whatever the [ __ ]
I want so keep on telling us about
attention I'm gonna find these jokes
attention so attention is anchored to
anchors and the example that Chris is
about to tell you is of a guy named
Anthony Jeselnik and you may not like
his brand of humor but consider him a
master of surprise he constantly creates
an anchor for you as a storyteller
and then he breaks that expectation in
humorous and oftentimes offensive ways
yeah so here's his his three jokes for
you listeners
my dad was amazing he raised five boys
all by himself without the rest of us
knowing we just found out my little
brother has a peanut allergy which is
very serious I know
but still I feel like my parents are
totally overreacting they caught me
eating a tiny little bag of airline
peanuts and they kick me out of his
funeral I've got a kid in Africa that I
feed that I clothe that I school that I
inoculate for 75 cents a day which is
practically nothing compared to what it
cost me to send him that I absolutely
love that the um it was this term that
you guys came up with that was called
violation of expectation and that is the
neuroscience definition of surprise I'm
gonna I'm gonna accuse people of
violating my expectation all the time I
absolutely adore that phrase yeah I mean
just you know as humans were naturally
forward projecting creatures right so
we're always trying to predict what's
gonna happen next if we weren't able to
predict people's behavior we you know
probably wouldn't be alive for very long
we always have to stay you know within a
reasonable future we're away from the
present always sort of predicted and so
in our unconscious state we're trying to
make predictions and these predictions
that play out for us internally and then
if what actually happens is a major
deviation from that it obviously leads
us to be surprised and that's what we
mean by by violation of expectation and
so when it comes to neuroscience there's
lots of places to study since is
studying the classic oddball paradigm
where you give people a stimulus and
it's in a certain location and they
become attending with it's looking at
that certain location and then you give
them in in a completely different
location you get a understands the if
you do this with MRI you get to
understand the neural basis for what's
this sort of redirection and so when
this a violation of expectation happens
you are having to recapitulate yourself
and you form a new hypothesis based on
that but the major thing in terms of
your behavior is it drives your
attention
so whatever you people accustomed to
whatever you're so the status quo is if
you have a huge violation from that and
what you've come to expect that status
quo it's gonna drive your attention and
the biggest example of that was Calgary
Calgary UK back in 2006 whatever UK
classic F&B rant and they had suffered
some some down revenue for a few years
with a salmonella outbreak and like oh
my god we have to do something really
really could be amazing to get everybody
to pay attention to us again and
probably the biggest thing they could
possibly ever have done is they got a
commercial and this is Cadbury money
this is a very classic British brand and
they had a gorilla playing in the air of
the night and that was a commercial Phil
: Amy what what an ass thank you what a
banging tune what's interesting is a bit
like yeah if you listen to Phil Collins
on you know any given evening there's no
violation of expectation but if you get
it from Cadbury you're a gorilla suit
give a huge violation of expectation so
it's not so much the actual stimulus
itself but what has been proceeding that
because that is what's gonna drive your
expectation and the final point about
camera which is interesting is they're
like oh my god it's working let's go
back to the same well and it doesn't
work so they get this a very similar ad
about six months late like alright let's
ride this this guerilla Phil Collins
thing and of course it was everyone saw
coming
I even so I even remember when they
brought that wasn't it something wasn't
the gorilla doing some else this time
yes yes it was it was the same fee but
it was something slightly different but
they didn't yeah they didn't zag quite
as you know as much as they should but
everybody saw it coming because it was
you know for me once you can't fool me
twice other things so yeah just really
interesting how these expectations get
established and then you know once you
once you violate people's expectation
you really can't do it again until they
built the new expectation yeah I suppose
also there there's too much randomness
you know if you get known as like the
random brand that's still an expectation
right the explanation is randomness
so you might actually be best off just
doing like a really boring advert you
know just get like the guy you know guy
in the shirt with no tie and like just
the suit Jack I'm talking about you
insurance premiums or whatever so let's
talk about experience in memory I know
you guys are big into memory I know this
is a part of the book that you dedicated
a lot of time and research to so let's
talk about memory let's yes do it can i
I just want to open with all right
pretend like you didn't read the book
Chris how would you define memory Oh God
can I recall something perfect yeah
perfect
Matt go for it I think that things are
good if you start off and up jump in
yeah so first memory is is many many
things so one of the things you you know
learner your first day of psych 101 is
you have this big chart and there's
explicit memory these implicit memory
there's procedural memory there's
physical learning is all these things
we're gonna sort of have one term that
collapse across all of these it's really
our brains attempt at connecting us to
the past and attempt is is really the
key word yeah so we feel and it's very
strange as well because it's one of
those areas where what we think of in
terms of our own experiences and
memories it's actually very very
different from the way it actually works
which I'm a very poor intuition for how
we record experiences and how would we
call them later so what it feels like is
more having an experience or having
experience right now we have the record
button on internally our brain flicks
that and we're just recording we're
taking in everything in and then we're
trying to recall this memory later we
feel like we're playing the rewind
button but it turns out that neither of
those are true so we're having an
experience we're only taking in some of
the information so some information is
is weighted more heavily than others so
are our brains prioritize certain piece
of information over others in terms of
what's likely to be remembered later so
you probably remember your first kiss
but you probably don't remember first
time you did taxes right so both of
these things were experiences you had
your your record button on but only one
is going to come to mind
Medellin so emotion plays a really
really huge role in making it more or
less likely that this
experience is going to be remembered
later and then you look at the recall of
memory and that is just an incredibly
reconstructive process so the types of
memories will be different that come to
mind and we're in a certain sort of
context so if we are we're drinking beer
right now some wine for example probably
all of our beer memories will come back
if we're having champagne
we'll probably think of all the
associations we've had with champagne
and celebration this and that so
everything is context dependent as well
so memory is fascinating for this this
major chasm between what we feel like is
memory in our memories and what memory
actually is in terms of science yeah
yeah I want to take a minute to connect
memory back to attention I know we
bridged over to memory one of the ways
that you can encode a memory deeper is
actually breaking the violation of
expectation right so there's many
different psychological experiences that
help kind of bury that memory deeper one
of those is breaking expectations and we
I think Matt and I spoke to I think her
name was Debbie Lily she she did the
events for Oprah she's literally she did
the you get a car you get a car you get
a car she's the mastermind behind that
yeah I mean we spoke to her for the book
and what's what's brilliant about Debbie
is she's doing all these things
intuitively
right so she you know she's not putting
this violation of expectation and memory
hacking if you will or experiential
marketing sort of a framework she just
has been doing this so long she's so
good at it but she did it completely by
Nature but think about violation
expectation now memory right you're
sitting in this audience you're lucky
enough to get seats to go see Oprah live
and all of a sudden you know Oprah gives
away gifts iphones what-have-you and all
of a sudden boom violation expectation
piece by piece this person won a car so
everyone stood all these people who got
pulled out of the audience earlier they
got a car okay oh my god can't believe
it they've never given away a car on TV
before this is not prices right my plane
is blown out and then all of a sudden
you find out oh wait we have another
surprise for you Oh what is it and then
you get a car you get and then it's just
like layers and layers of violations
expectations being violated and no and
then wouldn't matter look at it no
wonder why that is the most memorable
Oprah moment right it is it was 10 out
of 10 on violation violating your
expectations repeatedly and that's what
encoded that memory so deeply in pop
culture right yeah I mean that's it's
it's great but experience the marketing
so we're gonna go back to brands this is
where the flirtation happens right in
some ways when we're creating like
pop-up restaurants or pop-up brand
experiences super hot right now right
it's it's it's because they encode a
deeper memory of you you walk past an
Adidas store for the 50th time in last
year it doesn't even register right but
then if you walk past the park that you
usually go to to go workout and then
there's a shoe box the size of your
apartment complex and it looks like the
adidas shoe box and you go in there and
guess what they're selling stamps myths
and superstars and then it's gone the
week after what do they do they created
a memory by violating your expectation
of a normal commute and that's something
that it's it's that like I said
flirtation is a good way because I want
to be flirted as a consumer in those
ways you know and then brands want to do
it because yes of course like matt said
it there is that memory in there what's
really creepy about memory though like
to go back to what Matt said you know
it's like hitting record and hitting
play and we couldn't be further from the
truth is what happens further down the
line you know what we call them the book
memory remixed is really kind of creepy
not I want to tell them about what
happens to memory over time because I
think that I think I think it's really I
think the way you're gonna put it is
gonna be really creepy then we're over
time yeah yeah recall of memory and how
how accurate so to speak recall the
memory can and cannot be yeah yeah yeah
so in terms of memory so it is just this
incredibly reconstructive process we
don't remember things as they
objectively happened or even as we
actually experience them so there's this
subfield of never agree search called
false memories where we really see just
how suggestible and how creative these
memories are remixed and this is
pioneered by Elizabeth Loftus down at UC
Irvine uh so bring somebody in to lab
and she'll say that she got a an email
from her parents and the email said oh
I'm just you know I was the email is
detail
this amazing trip that you took with
your family to the circus and it was you
know beautiful blue sky and there's
clouds and you really really really
wanted the popcorn but your dad wouldn't
let you get the park remember that she
sort of just you know prodding them and
ends up hating this picture for them and
after a while and she's become adapted
this for herself she'll actually be able
to implant a memory of this experience
that never actually happened and once
this memory is implanted it is as
realistic as any of our actual memories
of things that actually happened to us
and similar effects have actually
recently shown with virtual reality as
well well you'll bring and this was done
ten years ago when virtual reality was
not as as potent that as realistic and
it is today this is done down at
Stanford and what they do is they bring
children into the lab and they have them
go on a dolphin diving trip whether it's
swimming with dolphins and it's very
kind of cool surreal experience all in
just virtual reality but they've brought
the children back I think it was two
months later and they filled a
questionnaire and and part of this
questionnaire had to do with this
dolphin experience and it turns out
about half the children actually miss
remember the experiences haven't been
real they thought their parents took
them to SeaWorld and they actually swam
with dolphins so we have these
experiences in our brain is is constant
part of putting together and doing its
best guess it sort of making things
consistent and makes sense
and especially for young children and
this can really easily be tricked in
this case think if you actually swam a
dolphins and really just sat in a you
know a really boring lab and put on
virtual reality goggles it's from a
philosophical perspective it's a really
interesting question that like what is a
memory if your experience of a thing is
as vivid and deep and happy as having
done the thing then what's the
difference between you having done the
thing and not and I was thinking about
this I was watching uhm the devil next
door on Netflix have you seen this so
it's a documentary about
a Ukrainian guy living in the United
States who was found to be ivan the
terrible' a nazi death camera and he'd
come over after world war two and
basically the entire trial was was this
person actually the person that was in
the Nazi death camps and they are
bringing up people who this is in maybe
2000 early 2000s so the survivors that
were able to identify him you know
you're talking like 60 year old 70 year
old people they've been through a lot of
trauma you know there was by definition
there were survivors of places like
Treblinka or ash whit's or whatever and
the first awful lot of the memory
quality was called into effect but I
actually found a really interesting
question being um how long after someone
does something are they still culpable
for the actions of their past self you
know like is the guy that's Ivan the
Terrible like imagine if he'd done 40
years of good what he didn't but at 40
years of charity work and he turned a
corner he was essentially by all
definition a new person you know every
cell in your body I think is it 7 years
it's replaced so it's like there is even
a cell in that the only thing that that
person that you're looking at has in
common with the person that you saw
before is they share experiences and
their body took up the exact spatial
dimensions that it's taken up and no one
else has that's the only thing that they
have in common but I think it's a really
interesting philosophical question right
like what is um what is an experience
when it relates to it being a memory if
the memory can be footage so easily is
for someone to then think it's something
else it's a fascinating topic yeah no
absolutely we are these sort of
perpetually changing beings we are
constantly changing we're a slightly
different person from one day for the
next to becoming wake up in the morning
we're a slightly different person and
really what is holding us all together
it's really memory it's our our memory
of our past our memory of yesterday our
memory of our core here in
self all of those years ago and so we're
not really the same person in terms of
all of those different experiences we
can be a very different person who can
change fundamentally there's actually
examples of people who did something
horrible they actually had a a brain
tumor that seemed to be directly
predicates that horrible axiom of food
murder region called the amygdala which
has to do with our our fear response and
it seems to that directly contributed to
this violent act the person did you take
out the brain tumor and you have a
person who is no more likely to commit a
violent crime and in the future than
anybody else in society and so do you
punish that person you can seize them in
the same way and and yes it gets the
same sort of philosophical question as
you were getting out there yeah it's
it's absolutely fascinating I think this
that is it the guy that climbed the bell
tower that Sam Harris uses in his in his
book waking up that's the example the
famous example right and he asked him
sayest the people to do an autopsy on
him after he shot himself and his family
and like five passes by she's obviously
just terrifying in itself well the
memory then what else causes memory to
encode you've got violation of
expectation what else can we do to
ensure that we remember stuff yes one
thing that you sort of touched on a bit
actually it sort of is related to the
philosophical aspect is the peak and
effect and so this was pioneered by
Daniel Kahneman as well using actually
colonoscopies so you have people come in
so you're already doing the colonoscopy
there's not a very very you know
comfortable type of procedure to undergo
as far as procedures go and now you have
this researcher who's like well we just
want to know exactly how painful this is
at every moment and so it gives people a
dial and that's your instruction just as
you're undergoing this painful procedure
how much pain you feeling in that moment
and this really led us to believe that
there was a big difference with what we
experienced in what we remember so it
turns out that it wasn't the average
amount of pain that people experience
that that led to painful memories
it was two things the peak of the
experience so if not to get too graphic
but the the doctor's hand slips and it
just causes this incredibly you know
acute sense of pain but just for a
millisecond and then it goes back to
normal
there's a really really intense peak
then if you ask the person to Beach
later well how painful was that
operation but they off that was the
worst operation of all time so this peak
has a major impact and also the end has
a major impact as well so it was really
painful the end the entire experience
will be rated very painfully and the
reason it it segues into this
philosophical conversation is because
they did a follow-up experiment but like
well the end seems to be very very
important what if we artificially just
elongate people procedure they'll have
the actual procedure then they'll have a
period at the end where we'll just leave
a colonoscopy device in there and
nothing's happening it's not comfortable
but it's not super painful
we'll make it longer so there's more
overall pain but the actual end of the
procedure is going to be less painful
and will they then remember the entire
procedures being less painful and the
answer is yes so if you make the end
less painful even though the overall
experience on average is more painful
you're in there for longer than you
would have otherwise you'd actually
remember the whole experience is being
less painful so it sort of poses this
this interesting ethical question so is
it okay to give somebody more pain more
aggregate pain if it means they'll
actually remember the experience as
being less painful this is like the
matrix is actually like the matrix you
know it's like what world are we living
at you we live in a world that our
brains perceive are we living in the
objective reality and the fact that our
brains are so fallible means that the
two actually don't don't match up belly
at all but it seems it sounds like a
complete miracle if your brain does
manage to interpret what's going on
around you accurately yeah slightly
tethered to three oh yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable so how
how can market is house how's this an
opportunity for market is when we get to
experience and memory how the market is
fit into this yeah let's so let's let's
piggyback on the peak end effect right
I'll give you a personal example and
then we can and we can expand out I I
recently did a TED talk and as I was
writing it 100% I'm thinking about peak
and effect okay so you can apply this to
when you're pitching startups for your
idea or any time you're on this journey
to to be remembered
I was testing different Peaks so I had
this funny moment in the TED talk where
I put my face on top of Adele it makes
no sense if you haven't seen it but that
was 100% planned so that way I can have
a peek in the entire 15 minute
conversation that would be memorable and
for marketers you can test multiple
Peaks but for a talk you got one to test
right and then at the very end I had a
very specific callback that referred to
something earlier so that I wanted the
end to be memorable as well so in just
public speaking you can use peak and
effect every time to talk okay and you
know when it comes to storytelling at a
grander scale with big budgets with
films films have an incentive to have a
really good ending that's why you don't
often see movies that have a have a how
do I say this an unsatisfactory ending
because people don't know resolution
yeah yeah it's because our brains we
want to remember the movie and we're
already inclined to remember the end of
it more so they can't mess up the end
right so and there's sort of a self-help
lesson here as well right like it's we a
lot of times we we we give an unfair
amount of weight to the end of something
like a movie
right you can have a movie that truly
might even change the way you think
about the world love whatever it might
be and then the last you know 15 minutes
of a two-hour movie it didn't end the
way you liked it and then that 15
minutes literally covers up entire two
hours of pure joy and whatever you want
to call it and we do that all the time
we forget that the that the journey that
got us there was actually really useful
until the end it's it's like the old you
know the William Shakespeare quote
well it's freakishly true and with that
right so you know so brands try to
create like go to a concert and and you
better have your biggest fireworks at
the very end but you also better have
one peak moment in between you better
bring out a guest star somewhere in
between that is unexpected that'll that
that will remember the concert your
whole set could have been trashed but if
you have a great peak and a great ending
it won't be remembered as being a bad
set it's unbelievable how easy but
humans are terrible aren't we so why do
we like what we like there's certain
preferences that we have there's certain
things that we lean toward and move away
from is it just artifacts of an
evolutionary time is it just Fitness
enhancing stuff it's it's a good
question so there's a lot of interesting
science about preferences and one really
consistent finding is that we generally
like things that we are familiar with so
from an evolutionary standpoint again if
you've seen something multiple times and
this thing hasn't eaten you and it
hasn't hurt you and it hasn't caused you
harm then that thing is is better than
something unknown on average and so this
is called the mere-exposure fact this is
Robert Sciences famous work there's
there's many many studies it's a very
consistent finding in in psychology that
all of us being equal we tend to like
things were exposed to multiple times
and a lot of his famous work was
actually done with Chinese characters
and so he brought non Chinese speaking
students into a lab he showed them a
bunch of Chinese characters and just
have them pay attention to them look at
them to come play with them he brought
them back two weeks later and he showed
them some of the characters he had seen
before and some new characters and he
asked them well what do you think these
mean and it seems were like no idea I
don't speak Mandarin Chinese I don't
know what these symbols mean at all it's
just just just humor me just guess and
so they just guess they just assigned
adjectives and down to these these
characters and it turns out the ones
that they had seen before these gods
adjectives like happy and love and
pleasure and pop emotions
hadn't seen before these were things
like table lamp but it's really regular
boring work so just by virtue of of
seeing something multiple times you tend
to like it a bit more and so that's
that's one set of major finding there
and then there's this seemingly sort of
conflicting finding here which is that
we also love being surprised so we love
pleasure even more when we can't predict
it so it's a violation of expectation we
tend to like it's a bit more and so
there's this a little bit of a parent
conflict there one we really really like
things that we're exposed to multiple
times the exposure effect on the other
side we have by election of expectation
prediction error
don't panic reaction all these things
from neuroscience showing us that we
actually like a bit of randomness
as well and the way this is resolved is
really interesting prints you wanna yeah
yeah so I mean it comes down to we like
the safety of the familiar but we also
like the I wants a danger but you're
also like the novelty of the unfamiliar
right it's the old birds of a feather
flock together or is it opposites
attract well the answer is what Matt and
I call not new and safe it's got to be
new enough but also safe enough so you
can when you start looking at this and
Matt and I love the example of pop
culture from music to film to truly look
at this you can see just how familiar
things can be and they won't get the
massive amount of adoption but if
they're to say to two out there then
they won't get massive amount of
adoption so if you're a marketer or an
entrepreneur and you're making a product
that you want to get massive adoption
and you have to think about knots and
then easy example this is look if you
want to if you want a new song to get
more adoption sandwich it in between two
known songs immediately that helps the
likeability of said new song the other
way to think about it is in terms of
just how culture slowly evolves and you
have certain things that were to to new
and unsafe that over time were
normalized and now and then they hit a
peak and then you hit you know the
Gladwell tipping point right you think
about modding cars was
very much underground until fast and
furious came out right timing and in
normalized it right the BDSM culture was
very much underground and unsafe until
shades of grey came out and the history
of shades of grey is fascinating because
it comes it was a fan fiction written
off of Twilight which itself is very
much a very safe take on vampires right
so but over time as you chip away at
this you know you look with the Naz
glasses that how these things were able
to even get popular it's because they
talked about something unsafe in a safe
manner at a place where people didn't
run away and yet the novelty was still
there that's so nas we yeah nas is
massive super cool it's awesome um have
you heard Matt this might be one for you
have you heard yeah about the
improvement in sleep quality when you
hear the sound of a snoring dog or a
crackling fire no you'll have to this
could be me talking out of my ass but
I'm pretty certain it's not I was told
about study where they played sounds of
dogs snoring and a fires crackling and
had a number of different control groups
and a number of different bits and the
most impactful sound on someone's sleep
was both fire crackling with dog snoring
because through our evolutionary history
that would be something that we would be
used to the fire crackling meant we were
still warm and safe from predators the
dog snoring meant that we had an alarm
sound that was gonna go that was gonna
protect us and that actually is embedded
in us now so it's not a learned behavior
it's something which sits in there and I
thought that was so cool also here's
another one for you
they did they took a number of different
groups of people and they looked at who
lives the longest right so group number
one single all the life
no no pets no family they lived an
amount of time then they took people who
had family family and dogs and just dogs
and they realized that people on their
own live a little bit shorter people
with family live longer people with
family and dogs live longer but people
with just dogs no family live longest of
all
crazy dog person right here you got me
bro so I thought that was a some coat
you can tell I just love dogs now I'm
just waiting for prints I'm just waiting
for you to bring your dog back on that's
all okay so let's talk you just touched
in BDSM there so let's talk about
pleasure and pain and how all of that
links together I'll let you take the
alley and then we'll get into it yeah so
first with pleasure
so pleasures also solutes and memories
it's really one of those areas where you
think we sort of have a firm idea of
what will make us happy what will give
us pleasure but we're really really bad
at actually navigating this space a lot
of the theories that we have in terms of
our own personal philosophies even if we
haven't explicitly made it known to
ourselves just what if what we're to to
be going by turn out to actually be
against our own interest and they don't
make us as happy as you think we do and
one of the main ways this this manifest
is in terms of these these very specific
milestones so we think we're gonna be
happening when we have 10,000 followers
of 20,000 50 whatever the case you know
maybe and a pleasure just like attention
seems to attenuate very quickly over
time so we hit this milestone and we're
happy for you know the 20 minutes will
possum ship it whatever the case may be
and then we'll sort of go back to our
regular baseline level of happiness so
just like attention pleasure seems to
attenuate there's this really beautiful
graph that's Adam alter created he's a
marathon runner he wrote irresistible an
awesome book everybody loved that part
so good yeah yeah yeah Adam we love that
we love it resistible we he even gave us
a shout out for the book and he read it
and he endorsed it so it was like the
biggest thank you so much Adam
Adams man yeah thank you yeah absolutely
of our striving for pleasure
on platforms on on social media
platforms and and Internet platforms
devices there's always these sort of
milestones you can strive for you can
always have you know this many followers
your life's work the case may be and we
think we're gonna be happy with Peaks
that meeting talks about this in the
context of marathon runners do you think
about marathon runners and there should
be a a you know a pretty even
distribution of ability so you think
about something like finishing times for
a marathon it should reflect this
general distribution so we're all you
know we have a normal distribution in
terms of our ability there should be a
normal distribution in terms of
finishing time but it's not what we see
at all around these to the arbitrary
cutoff points you have a four-hour
marathon you know three and a half hour
three hour to half hour
you see these surgeons you see these
these Peaks so you're really really
trying to get that for our really really
trying to get that three hour if you you
know know you're gonna get 3:45 you know
that's a lot of cool you know milestone
to tell anybody so you're not really
gonna push yourself that that extra
amount and there's all these really
interesting and a total stories of
people who you know works for five ten
who can use to get that you know three
hour mile climb two-and-a-half hour mile
time and they finally get it it's no you
go you'll celebrate that lighter you'll
feel good about it and it's a sense of
accomplishment but you know in in terms
of your overall level of happiness you
tend to go back down to your baseline
this is what Dan Gilbert and others Paul
impact by its well we're generally bad
at understanding just how events are
going to impact us impact our level of
happiness and so we as a result we can
sometimes strive for the wrong things
you sort of strive for this this
dangling carrot that isn't actually
gonna make it happy once we get there
it's just gonna be dangled out in front
of us even further you yeah it's you
know it's called the pursuit of
happiness for a reason because it ain't
about achieving it right because the the
happiness it goes away it's in the chase
and I think one example that will never
get old for me is a new iPhone every
year a new iPhone every year you look
forward to this thing you don't know why
you look forward to this thing it comes
out you get it and then you're moving on
right but man Apple is brilliant
for doing it do I know for sure if in
the boardrooms at Apple Apple's like ooh
let's have let's optimize this
unpredictable a pleasure chase and the
sadhana treadmill and keep getting them
one maybe maybe not I can't say for sure
only applicants say that but I can one
thing Matt and I can say for sure is
this is exactly why we fall for this
every single year new iPhone we're in
the chase of we think the new iPhone is
gonna make us happy pleasure Peaks
before in the chase and then you get it
and then it's fleeting it attenuates
like Matt said princess am i right am i
right in saying the the anticipation of
an event is often more pleasurable than
the event itself and this was actually
someone told me this about I'm people
getting ready for nights out exam
occurred promoter that's what I do I'm a
nightclub promoter and they were rating
people's happiness
I don't know how objective this was or
whether it was a subjective measure and
a people's happiness was rated at the
highest just as they were about to call
the taxi to go on the night now so
they've had the pre drinks maybe the
girls have got ready with each other and
they've done each other's makeup and
they're having a few glasses of
champagne or wine or whatever and that
period was you know it was a line with
what you guys have found absolutely it's
such a it's such a great example that's
exactly what neuroscientist have found
in a range of stimuli so when you you
know take out club and put chocolate
cake you actually experience pleasure
you can measure this in the nucleus
accumbens in terms of the dopaminergic
response you get to the optimal response
right before it touches your tongue I
really find anticipation itself to be
intrinsically rewarding and
intrinsically pleasurable and a lot of
times why it's a good question it's it's
it may have some evolutionary origins
that you are sort of driven to chase so
if you imagine you really want to eat
this you know delicious bison and you
finally reach that bison you get it and
you it's just as good as we thought it
was gonna be your your brain created a
model for how this is gonna taste when
you finally taste it and it drove you to
to catch this bison once you get this
bison is good as is your brain promised
it was going to be you'd never feel the
need to chase another bison ever again
you need to have this sort
at slight discrepancy between what you
think it's gonna feel like and what you
think it's gonna taste like and what it
actually does it sort of keeps us moving
contentment is a fantastic human emotion
but it is an evolutionary that exists it
can tell cavemen is a dead caveman so
our pleasure systems are constantly
pushing us to seek more yeah it's a
reproduction it's food think about it
because you're forced to push yourself
to achieve something food or a partner
and then you want more food right if we
didn't want to continue to have sex we
wouldn't have more children and we
wouldn't have human race with that like
matt said it perfectly a Content caveman
is a dead caveman indeed have you heard
this quote from Schopenhauer about after
copulation have you heard this no what
is it directly after copulation the
devil's laughter is heard that's
Schopenhauer and he's identities
identifying that like whatever is the
post coital depression that a lot of men
say that they suffer with you do and
you're like that was that was fantastic
you you know it's not your problem but
there's just this like kind of inkling
of an existential crisis that's just
looming at the back of my head and I
don't actually know why it's there and
it's urban house search on it then you
totally write like why would you go and
have sex again if sex every time you had
sex was as satisfying as you thought it
was going to be or why would you then go
and chase down the Bison so I guess
dissatisfaction being programmed into us
is Fitness enhancing for us to continue
to chase that satisfaction right it's
almost like you've taught me something
today gentlemen I'm just learning
solving it absorbing it like a like a
sponge so we've talked about about
pleasure and pain how does that affect
our drive to by how the market is tap
into that I mean it's either turn up the
pleasure or turn down the pain to get to
a purchase right so the pleasure that I
received from the purchase of said
product must be so high that whatever
pain
took me to achieve it it's it overrides
it or the other way around right the
most objective form of pain when buying
a product is the money that goes out of
your wallet into the wallet of the other
company right so you think about just
over the years the payment technology
and how friction-free it's gotten right
you know I remember thinking it was
weird that I can have a lyric from my
favorite song ten years ago type that
into Amazon and it'll complete the
purchase and I don't even have to do
that you know Alexa buy me a new
notebook and it's already Alexa hey pal
was a game changer because you don't
have to type in your credit card but
that was almost twenty years old now
right like so the pain of payments is
good for everyone it's good for you if
you want to slide pass and not have to
stop to think it's bad for you if you
have bad spending habits but it's good
for everyone selling you stuff so we can
go down the rabbit hole of pain and what
that actually means in terms of user
experience and customer experience but
nonetheless reducing pain increasing the
pleasure helps buy purchases and you can
see now the put Apple in that
perspective right they didn't want to do
retail until the retail right and the
retail if nothing else is a textbook
example of how to create minimal
friction as much as possible and of
course the pleasure derived from apple
products has been well-documented and
that's you know it's not the only reason
why they're successful but that's a
great perspective to look at Apple part
of the whole experience right so I had a
Alex Kantrowitz son who's a tech
reporter for BuzzFeed and he's got this
new book out called always day one and
he went into one of these new Amazon Pat
pantry stores where you Amazon yeah we
have where you um you just pick up stuff
and walk out like you shoplifting
apparently he's he's in SF so I guess it
must be that'll be where they'll be
testing this austere and it looks like
it felt like I felt like such a boss I
felt like I'd shoplifted forklift bars
out of there and then about thirty
seconds later my Apple card pay popped
up and said like you just got forklift
buzz from Amazon Girl store or but yeah
yeah I totally get it so again rolling
on from that mural
coupling I want to know what that means
because I saw it in the book and I
didn't have time to read it so what's
what's a neural coupling yeah so this is
a really interesting phenomena which
really explains how we are able to
communicate so communication is one of
those things where you just you did say
something somebody understands it and
and there there's some sort of magic
that takes place but we don't really
understand it it turns out that there is
this really interesting alignment which
takes place between speaker and listener
and there's actually some research that
I got to be a part of back in graduate
school so what we did is we had our lab
met Lauren lie inside fMRI functional
magnetic resonance imaging and we just
eavesdrop on her brain as she told the
story of her high school prom and it was
a really really debauchery story there
was a ball that it was lots of luck it
was a very engrossing story so your task
is a participant afterwards was just a
lie awake in the upper my story and
listen to Lauren story so we recorded it
we had a special microphone the letter
to tell that story watches the scanner
and then as a participant you just live
in the scanner and listen to that story
and then after you got this these two
data points that we have Lauren's brain
as she's telling story we have the
participants brain as they're listening
to that story and what was interesting
is we did a specific analysis to
actually not see differences between the
brains but I could see where in the
brain dooms the most similarity over
time this is called inner subject
correlation so you can basically do a
correlational analysis at every small
little box hole in the brain to see how
similar the brains of speaker and
listeners were and it turns out that the
more the person comprehended the story
the more similar their brain was for
Lauren's brain so we had everybody take
a test after the gun of the scanner just
how much you get is in a story this you
know true/false question this
multiple-choice question just an
objective measure of understanding and
we use that to correlate with the the
intercepted correlation analysis and the
more you understood the story the more
similar your brain was to Lauren's brain
and so this is this really interesting
way of thinking about communication so
my job as
the speaker if I'm trying to communicate
something it's my job as a speaker to
inculcate the same brain activity in my
brain as I'm telling a story into your
brain
and the better I'm able to do that more
my brain looks like your brain the
better I've succeeded as a communicator
and so this is the phenomena of neuro
public that's that's actually the end
goal of communication in a in a kind of
a very broad definition is to make the
other person's brain experience the same
thing that your brain is experiencing
exactly exactly and actually this has
been studied with with movies as well so
one of the other experiments we did was
actually look at how similar people's
brains are as they're watching the same
film so we sit down in the movie theater
we all like something different for
breakfast one of us you know broke up
with his or her boyfriend you know we
all have two creatures going into it but
it turns out there's this one director
but when you sit down and you watch
their films everyone's brains are almost
identical any any guesses for this is
Chris Quentin Tarantino know that he was
he was out of there this is Alfred
Hitchcock no way so Alfred Hitchcock
just has incredible ability to have this
gripping effect on his audience so on
that day doesn't matter what you ate for
breakfast doesn't matter what
relationship status you are when you sit
down for an hour when Hitchcock movie
you are having the same experience as
the person next year so it's it's a
really really sort of foundational way
in which communication takes place we
really have a shared experience and we
can see that manifested through shared
neural activation that's thick yeah so
cool it's it's wild it's communication
really is like a game of Tetris
it's how I can manipulate the piece
being the sender and have the fit in the
receivers mind to truly connect
literally to connect what I mean and you
see this in brands all the time and I
love it because I can give you all these
great examples of how brands have done
really well with neural coupling but I
think it's more fun to look at when they
screw up so let's look at one example I
was caught right as a marker you're
always communicating it doesn't matter
if you're the head of HR or the head of
CEO you got to communicate to your team
right so one of the things
so we're in San Francisco Oakland and
one of the things is there's just not
right now because it's kovat but in
general there's a massive competition to
hire people right so tech companies are
doing all sorts of stuff to bring on new
new employees and they're fighting over
each other it's wild and of course
Microsoft wants a piece of the pie right
so this is a this is exactly how you
don't know early couple so of course
there's a I'm gonna read this out loud
okay no long coupling would be like if
we were on if we're sitting with Joe
Rogan there's a way we talk it would be
different from us being interviewed by
Barbara Walters right we're not really
coupling we're going to say honest to
our brand but we're gonna know really
couple to make sure that we resonate
with the audience right so this is
Microsoft's attempt at bringing new
interns on let me see if I have it I
thought I had it written out so this is
an actual email we have a screenshot of
it on the website that's up the email
opens up like this hey BAE intern I am
Kim a Microsoft University recruiter my
crew is coming down from our HQ to
Seattle from Seattle to hang out with
you and the cat of Bay Area interns at
interna Palooza on 7-eleven but more
importantly initiatives in all caps bold
underline and italicize all the above
we're throwing an exclusive afterparty
none of the event at our San Francisco
office and you're invited
there will be hella noms lots of drinks
the best beats and just like last year
we're breaking up the Yammer beer bond
last one hell yes to getting lit on a
Monday night make you stop you know what
but that's what they're trying to do
they're trying they don't know they
might not know what no a coupling is but
innately you know that if I connect with
you by communicating with you the way
you want to be communicated you'll
connect with me back hey this is a
failure there's obviously a minimum and
maximum authenticity that brands needs
to catch with in getting outside of
whatever the authenticity equivalent of
the Overton Window is and falling
outside of that it causes my toes to
curl
yeah just it's just just so cringy it is
and you know in some part of the world
with a different brand you could
probably deliver that authentically for
their different type of audience but it
just didn't feel off and if that was in
front house and you know like if that
was a front she asian or something you'd
be like yeah yes yeah yeah yeah hell yes
- getting laid on a Monday night yep no
that's exactly what it is it's uh yeah
often you know our brains have a BS
meter you know we're constantly looking
at patterns in the world and and if
there's one thing our brains are decent
at is the BS meter you know we might not
know why but there there's that that
feeling we might get every now and then
and and it's that it's your brain trying
to pick up a break in the pattern but
you may not be totally conscious of it's
interesting yeah so we touched on mr.
alters work earlier on and I know that
you guys did some stuff to do with how
compulsive behavior gets monetized in
the digital age can we touch on that
I'll say this now I'm gonna piss off all
the marketers listening to this when it
comes to products that are tech products
that are free and I'm using quotes here
engagement is another way of measuring
addiction engagement is just not
socially vilified right people you know
you look at YouTube's engagement
statistics IG is engagement engagement
engage of engagement it's a very nice
way of saying this is how well this is
how good I am at keeping you heart okay
now it's not always a bad thing because
sometimes people do want to be engaged
if you want to Netflix if you want to
binge on Netflix the Netflix has all the
incentive in the world to help create an
experience that helps you bench right so
I'm not saying it's all bad but just
know that engagement is a nice way of
saying we got you hooked for this long
and there's many different things I
think Maddie should you should break
down this ignore effect I think that's a
good way to start this off yeah well
maybe first just connecting it back with
with pleasure a bit because it does a
connect actually with something we
talked about before which is this idea
of pleasure and surprise so we like
things a bit more when we can't predict
they're going to happen
and the really scary thing is is that
then when we were on a reward schedule
which you can't predict that actually
shapes behavior to a far greater extent
and so what what'll of these platforms
do is they deliver an anticipated
pleasure and so you go on your Instagram
feed you go on your Facebook feed you go
in snapchat and there's something akin
to the newsfeed and you know it's
generally gonna be plentiful there's to
be something in there you're gonna like
don't when it's gonna happen where it's
gonna happen how it's going to be
delivered and this element of
uncertainty in a very strange way
actually drives behavior in a really
potent way and this comes back to
experiments which were done in 1960s
Michael Zieler and his famous pigeon
experiment we gave pigeons a ability to
peck at a lever and get a reward and
there was two different levers set up
one you can Peck the lever and you would
get a kernel of food something rewarding
to the pigeon every three pecks the
other one you pecks the lever and on
average you get a kernel of food every
three packs or four packs but you don't
know when it's gonna happen so sometimes
you get it immediately sometimes you get
tuna row three in a row sometimes you
peck for seven times you don't get one
so you don't know what it's gonna happen
as a variable reward schedule is what
it's called and to everyone's surprise
the pigeons could not stop pecking at
the variable schedule so instead of
getting this kernel of food consistently
when they could expect it they wanted
one that actually introduced a little
bit of variable pleasure because that's
the pledge that really drives behavior
at a very sort of strange way going back
to the sort of strange workings of our
dopaminergic system we find anticipation
more rewarding we can't predict
something's gonna happen we're
anticipating it in anticipation itself
is the warning and keeps us going and
this is exactly what a lot of these tech
platforms have converged on to so you
know that your Instagram feed is gonna
be generally pledge oppose me somebody's
cute baby your dog for you for you Chris
somebody's cute puppy or their dog but
you know when it's gonna happen you
don't know where they're gonna be in the
park you don't know they're there's some
element of uncertainty this general
pleasurable experience and that is this
really really key reward system that
drives behavior
compulsively and it's really interesting
looking back at the the evolution of
these platforms so Facebook being the
famous example so way back in Princeton
eyes college days Facebook was just a
series of these individual pages just
went on people say you guys and you
liked a photo or you poked them or
invited them for the vampire fight
whatever these weird apps are on
Facebook and when they created the the
actual common newsfeed everybody hated
it they actually wrote ahead of product
these very very vicious emails oh my god
you you ruined Facebook this is before
before hashtag this is cancel Facebook
everybody hated it but was interesting
as they looked at the stats and their
actual time on sites I rocketed people
claim to hate this thing but having this
this was the key way of introducing this
variable reward and this cause time on
sites and an engagement to skyrocket so
yeah these these platforms have really
converged on to this fundamental way
which are pleasant suspensions work and
they've but of comported in a way where
they maximize users time on site did you
see I can't remember the lady's name she
used to work for as a consultant for
casinos and she's now involved with
Tristan Harris at the the scent of the
humane technology and she wrote a book
about all of the crazy ways I'll try and
I'll try and find it and I'll send it to
you guys are so good of the crazy ways
that casinos keep people on the floor so
for instance the carpets never have
right angles in the patterns the way
that the flow of people is encouraged
around and this than the other annum
there's a wait I don't know if it's
still programmed into Twitter because
obviously the kind of the veil got
released here but um when you log on to
Twitter on your phone there is a
programmed wait between when you arrive
on the site and when the notification
number pops up on the notification bell
and that wait is precisely the same
length of time that it takes a slot
machine to go from hitting the button
until coming back and this lady had
identified it and as soon as you realize
that these guys are playing around with
the same stuff that like Vegas casinos
are doing and using
variable rewards and and stuff like that
that's when you know I'm I am up against
a lot of power that is so so far beyond
and and Chris this goes back to what we
said I what I said earlier we have to
bridge this gap man right like it's I'm
lucky enough to be a consumer and a
marketer and that's you know it's not
transparent you know what I mean you're
going into a casino at least you know
that this entire experience is designed
to get you to gamble there's age limits
and even then it's it's your it's your
own volition that you do it you don't
know that when you're signing up for IG
right you don't exact and we haven't
even gone down the rabbit hole of what's
gonna happen with this data down the
line of which is really paying for it
that's a whole other conversation right
so of course you know like it kind of it
kind of breaks my heart a bit to hear
you say oh when they're playing with the
same stuff that the casinos are to
create these apps for us that does break
my heart because that's the distrust
that I've talked about in the very
beginning it does make you not trust
apps even though yeah I want to go on
Twitter and read dog [ __ ] I want to go
on Facebook and keep in touch with my
old friends but there is that level of
distrust and and and and us as marketers
have to own that and us as consumers
have to own it too and there's and
there's you know we can talk more about
how to exactly to own it but that's sort
of why we wrote this book is to reduce
that mistrust we want consumers to know
the psychological impact but we also
want consumers to own the fact that you
know what we want to use these products
I can agree this is so bad so much
distrust you know between consumers I
think and marketers at the moment and um
it's when it's when marketers have been
able to weaponize particular parts of
our behavior in ways that we didn't
request them to do you know and um I
could go on about this for ages I had
Chi weigh the CEO of the light phone I
had him on he was episode 10 and that
was you know two and a bit years ago so
I've been thinking about this for quite
a while a lot of the listeners will be
very familiar with it as well but you
are right I think that there needs to be
a corner that's perhaps turned by
marketers generally you know I
don't mind Rory Sutherland or Richard
shot no Bruce took with or whoever it
might be are you guys using known
psychological effects to make me love
brands you know I want I want to feel
warm I want to feel like if I buy a
Harley Davidson I'm gonna be like a
freewheeling mother you know it just a
handmaiden blasting out the side like
that's cool I don't mind that but there
is I think that there was an asymmetry
in terms of who had the weapons in this
for a while
you know and it's like they some people
manage to run away so much further ahead
of where consumers were the the fight
was almost unfair and I think that that
might have been the advent of mobile
technology and we've seen this before
we've seen innovation comes in and in
highly capitalist societies like the US
where we're primarily innovation in
capitalism secondarily consumer rights
and consumer advocates right that's you
can see a history of public policy and
how it always favors capitalism we have
really cool products and then consumers
eventually find out what it takes to get
there and then they pass out for the
policy catches up and then the cool and
then the cool innovation comes up so
we're always playing catch-up
and I think I think if that's how life
is in the u.s. great you know but it's
time for policy to catch up but I think
you're right though I love that you said
that there's an imbalance of this
weaponry of sorts and I think it's
really easy to point the finger at
Facebook and I think you can go do
everyone can do it I'm not defending
Facebook what I really wanted to do
though is I want to empower the
consumers man I believe that consumer
power isn't this [ __ ] thing that we
talked about I genuinely believe in the
power of the consumer I think that if
you me and Matt convinced five people
each to pay a dollar a month for
Instagram to have a private Instagram
and stop doing all the shady [ __ ] that
they do Instagram will want to do that
it's we have found ourselves in this
weird oxymoron state we want free as
consumers especially in the internet
world like think about all the work
you're putting in right now to put this
podcast together right we're not paying
you you're not paying us we're just
spending our hard-earned time to do this
why are you not charging for this
podcast that is tremendous value well
because people aren't willing to pay for
it
you know what I mean so what do we do
right so it's oh there's the knees and
what I'm saying with the bridging thing
is let's have that conversation right if
consumers come out and say I'll pay $1
for an app that is not that is an
alternative to whatsapp then someone
will actually have an incentive to make
that and create a new business model the
business model in modern tech is built
upon three three being the consumer and
how much they're willing to pay right so
as soon as that changes we force the
business models to change new business
models will rise and fall you know a and
and you know I don't know if you use
signal or telegram or brave all these
browsers and all these chat apps are now
finally going we don't want to do a data
based approach on creating a free
product brave did it by creating their
own cryptocurrency and that's what keeps
it private signal right now is not even
asking for money and it's encrypted
end-to-end text messaging no matter what
so five years ago didn't exist now they
do so eventually they're gonna start
asking for donations and eventually that
evolves into a place where it's like
consumers get what they want and the
people making these products marketers
just programmed to create stuff that
plugs in your attention because just
assume consumers will forever want free
and I don't I think we're coming I think
slowly we're coming to the point where
it you know wishful thinking partially
but also trying to predict something I
think that might change I don't know how
long it'll take but I could change but I
think it might change I think I think
conversations like these with you and
you're really the you're the vessel
through which people learn this stuff
right like you're the vessel you're you
you have your the transport of this
information and you're not the only one
like we've got immense interest in
people talking about the stuff that's in
the book I think that's a sign of stuff
shifting and and I think as people learn
for it more they're really gonna realize
that dollar a month is not that much to
pay for a messaging app that you use a
thousand times a month that doesn't
track you know that you're crying about
your dog or your it's I hope this is
where we go
I truly hope or this this is where we go
because the distrust is not it's not a
good place to be yeah man I I'm fully
fully on board I think
a lot of deprogramming that needs to be
done sort of consumer expectations about
what's happened in your right there's
been such a flurry oh there was such a
flurry of innovation probably the last
15 years
that's the weaponry that brands
marketers tech companies had to play
with was so much further ahead from even
our cultural and our social norms you
know we didn't even have words to
describe the sorts of things that were
happening to us
you know like tech addiction or screen
time you know all of these sorts of
things they're only recent inventions in
so that we now have an objective measure
of how we can manage our own use of
these new products you're totally right
the innovations gonna move more quickly
then first the policy can then social
norms then the way that people learn to
deal with it and all this sort stuff so
you know I genuinely do believe that the
more that people can educate themselves
about how brands and how companies use
psychological effects and this is this
is one of the main reasons that I love
doing the podcast and specifically have
a very soft spot for purpose in life
psychology biases Eve psyche stuff like
that B the reason is that I think
understanding why we are the way we are
and why we like the things we like and
then also perhaps even giving people at
least a little bit of a site of how they
could deprogram some of those unpro
unconscious wants and needs allows them
to experience life in the most liberated
way that they can because until you
deprogram all of that stuff the best
that you can hope for is to become a
famous rich or wealthy slave that's the
best that you can hope for that's all
you've got to play around with until you
decide you're going to say no until you
decide to deprogram this is a big
advocate for sobriety for the same
reason I like people pushing themselves
to go sober in a world that tells them
to drink because as soon as you realize
that you choose to drink not you have to
drink because it's just what everybody
does it makes a really big change and I
think you know whatever equivalent this
is kind of like sobriety for consumers
blind sights a little bit like going
sober for consumers which actually
actually really like so I've got three
three questions I'm gonna ask you guys
now to finish up first one this is for
each of you
what was your favorite study from your
research during all of the research what
was the favorite thing that you guys
stumbled across could have been
something you already knew about or
something new oh this is tough I'll take
this one first Matt if that's okay with
Mandy this goes down the freakish the
weird matrix theme that we've converged
upon in here I'll do the Haines study on
pushing buttons so they put people in
the fMRI machine and they have them
choose between two things blue bike red
bike you know fluffy dog hairless dog
whatever and they're looking at these
images and they're simply asking them
choose one okay but looking at the brain
they were able to predict before the
person even push the button which one
they were going to predict which one
they were going to choose not just one
second half a second a full seven
freakin seconds before they click the
button they know what button you're
going to pick and this isn't like 60%
certainty we're talking absolute
certainty seven seconds before pushing
the button seven seconds is a lot of
time Colby has made a career rest in
peace out of hitting jump shots at the
seven second seven second is a lifetime
the fact that and I loved that study a
it's kind of creepy in matrix U right
but also let's take a step back we think
we are objective pilots on the life of
an airplane that we're on we think we
know exactly why we're doing what we're
doing and when we do it and at least
when we do it part is completely
incorrect right this there's parts of
the brain that subconscious that is that
we can measure right now in life and
lifetime that will tell us what you're
going to do before you actually do it so
you're not this objective pilot I think
you are so that's what there's so many
but I picked that when Corinne seeking
out think about it I sent one of my good
buddies Luke into the worst two week
spiral of depression of his life by
teaching him the free will wasn't real I
read build him I read pilled him about
some heresies free wills speech on Joe
Rogan and I didn't seem that I didn't
see him for two weeks and he came back
and he took me to one side and he was
like dude I've been in the worst mood
with you ever for the last two weeks so
I felt that my life had no meaning I had
this any other
because I but then actually I've come
out the other side now and I've realized
that it's totally fine that I actually
you know I'm on this journey and bla bla
and I was like you have been to hell and
back in a place of three weeks and this
is the problem with giving people
concepts but yeah I absolutely loved
that seven seconds before someone knows
what they're going to do and it does
show the fal ability of our belief that
we are the pilots of our own actions
right so Matt what's what's your pick
from the from the litter yeah so for me
it's actually a study which is find
similar conclusions about freewill
through a different way and this is
through the lens of memories I'm a huge
memory geek this is what a lot of my PhD
work focused on so this is the the
Nesbitt and Wilson study from the 70s so
they just had people enter into the lab
and they had this array of stockings on
the wall and they chose stockings
because nobody really knows you know
anything about sake nobody has you know
baseline preferences for stockings so
it's an area of high uncertainty and
they just ask the people well which
stockings do you want which ones you
think are the best and so they made
their selection and then they asked them
well why did you make that selection and
it turns out that humans for this very
strange reason nobody quite knows we
have this right-side bias so when we
walk into a room we tend to go to the
right side we look at a picture we tend
to look to the right side of the picture
and the same thing with the stocking
race so people regardless of the color
whatever just pick the ones on the right
because they have no idea but what what
was interesting about Vivi studies they
asked me why don't you pick the ones
that you picked and it was like well I
like the color on this one I kind of
just you know spoke to me this one
reminded me of my grandmother this buddy
this one you know the the the cloth felt
you know really really really you know
high-quality all of these reasons that
had nothing to do with their actual
choice so everybody just picked the one
on the right side of the array but
nobody had any idea that they had this
bias and so once we'd make this it just
it just went to show that once you make
a someone we go into a decision we don't
know all the full variables and factors
that lead us to make a choice and once
we make this choice we feel this need to
justify our decision we feel this need
to to confabulate to see ourselves
as consistent eating's and to explain it
to ourselves in a way that makes sense
so this to me was was a really really
fascinating experiment they've done
similar studies with JME they bring the
consumers into a room which woods jam do
you like and they'll pick you know the
one on the right just because it's the
one on the right and then they ask Wow
oh I love blueberry I love you know all
these reasons that have nothing to do
with the actual choice but was that
choices made they just confabulate it to
themselves so a lot of what marketing is
is is making these two by two these
little tweaks to then allow consumers
not necessarily to inform their choice
but to allow them to justify it to
themselves afterwards so we find this
example of Hummer for example where they
have Hummers and nobody buys covers for
take people buy Hummers because you know
huge gas guzzling thing you want to feel
like a man whatever that's where the
it's a hedonic motivation to buy a
Hummer generally but they found when
they put these little decals on the
Hummer hey why did you buy a home and
the decal say you know safety ratings or
this and that people will claim it was
the safety ratings which led them to buy
the Hummer in the first place as you
find these little things that don't
necessarily factor into the choice but
allow us to justify it to ourselves
later so for me is the the Nesbit study
and this whole idea of confabulation
which is it's super fascinating it's so
cool I guess the problem is that as
we've identified today anybody that's
listening and still considers themselves
a rational objective decision-maker
evidently hasn't taken in anything that
we've talked about because you just a
mess of hormones and water and and
muscles desperately trying to see the
world for something that resembles what
it is and it's not all and you're just
living in like Willy Wonka land it's
like [ __ ] miss dr. Zeus out there
isn't it yeah it's what God is well bit
it's not as if Prince and I haven't
researched this and and written this
book that were somehow like a mute to
all bees we're we're no better than
anybody else so once you see how the
sausage is made you don't not want the
sauces you know so we're you know you
just hate yourself more for having eaten
it aasif eating yeah do you hear
Daniel Kahneman on the knowledge project
with Shane Parrish last year no Daniel
Kahneman basically doesn't do podcasts
right but Shane Irish guy behind FS top
bloke farnum's street unbelievable
blogger top top level podcaster he's
booked on modern wisdom as soon as this
lockdown finishes I'm gonna go a Canada
and see him in Ottawa but he gets Daniel
Kahneman on and he asks Daniel
so has your 40 50 year career of
understanding these heuristics and
biases has it helped you to become a
more rational human being in any way and
Daniels answer was essentially no he was
like you know you've got a Nobel Prize
winner in the interview who spent his
entire life working out how the brain
works and who's that now I'm still just
kind of just as screwed as everybody
else if there's no hope for Daniel
Kahneman then us as mere mortals have no
chance at all
so second to last question you're each
stuck on a desert island with only one
mental model psychological effect or
bias each which one are you taking with
you one bias which one am i taking with
me so what's my favorite bias I don't
know Matt if you have an answer I don't
think about it for a second I think I
would take in the the impact bias so the
impact bias basically says that we are
generally poor acts sort of
understanding how things affect our
overall happiness and we as then Gilbert
says we underrate our psychological
immune systems so for me whatever
happens on the desert island I hope I
would have that - it might remind me you
know if I you know get bit by a crab and
I lose a toe it's fine if I you know you
can't get get to a new part of the
island and find some delicious coconuts
that's fine too but you know it's a bit
level headed because I'm just gonna fall
down to my base like that's so much more
sophisticated than I thought I thought
you were just gonna say like inversion
or the contrast effect
map versus terrain or something like
that and you've actually taken something
with you that's like a Batman utility
belt that's gonna help you survive
that's pretty that's pretty impressive
the pressures
no prints what you what he's gonna go
for mine mine is strictly survivalist
the hedonic treadmill look if I'm stuck
on an island I want to be in the shitty
pursuit of happiness that keeps me
hunting and hunting and hunting because
it increases my chance of survival so
I'm gonna go with that the fact that
pleasure is fleeting and it's gonna
hopefully increase my likelihood of
surviving on an island by myself I love
it so final thing is what does the
future of marketing have in store while
your guys predictions as we move forward
into the future Oh Matt I'll take this
one first yeah I I think we touched upon
this earlier I think the future of
marketing is going to be more
psychological okay I think the future of
marketing is going to be psychological
for companies that are not big right now
people who know neuro marketing in terms
of companies are bigger brands that
coca-cola's the world and of course the
data companies of the world Google and
Facebook I think I think we're getting
to a point where small to midsize
companies will be able to exercise some
of this stuff I think the future of
marketing is psychographics I think
we've been in the graphic sorry that
psychographics are an understanding of
your customers psychology and it and it
sort of piggybacks on the on the word
demographics demographics is aid sex
location all these different ways all
these quantifiable ways well you put
your customers in the category
psychographics are more what I call APO
it's your it's your attitudes and your
principles and your interests and your
opinions right it's not just about age
sex location it's about APO it's all
those little psychological aspects of
you that make you who you are right so I
think the future is psychographics and
the future is no longer going to be
stuck in a fortune 500 companies
databank but I also think for consumers
in the same way we thought we had power
when you can review a bad real estate
agent or a bad restaurant on Yelp and
give them 5 stars I think we are and
this is it might take a lot longer than
5 years but I think the future is
ownership of data the future is you mean
as consumers wake up and say we want to
own our data right our data is being
harvested in the creepy matrix sense for
so long and we've been drunk and high
off of free that we've let it happen
I think if in future we will and I think
that will be the rise and fall of
business models and I think that will be
sort of the catching up we talked about
earlier until some other stuff happens I
think that's the one that I my heart
truly believes maybe not my brain as
much but my heart truly believes that we
will find ways to to have a sense of
ownership and control over our own data
not just point finger at Facebook and
say you're evil no no fine find a happy
medium and open that conversation it's
awesome Mott yeah so for me it's
definitely another heart answer this is
the way I would I would really like to
see things unfold and that is through
experience and this is very very Pro vid
contingent so we're gonna have to see
how things play out there but we've seen
in recent years the sort of resurgence
of experiential marketing so if you look
at the digital world you can go on
Spotify you can have any song that's
ever been written every penny every
digital recording at the click of a
button you go on Amazon or Netflix
Amazon Prime or Netflix you can watch
any movie that's ever been in any
archive ever so these digital
experiences are commodified and what we
can't commodify is direct experience you
can't commodified experience of going to
an amazing concert and having that
moment to moment experience that
actually encoded memory that you're
gonna take for the rest of your lives
and what we're seeing now and what we
did see prior to the pandemic is a lot
of these major publishers and companies
that work in digital industries actually
going to the experience side so in a
Yorker festival for example The New
Yorker magazine obviously and a lot of
their their revenue has been going
steadily down as most publishers have
because most of this they do have a you
know a fervent loyal fan base but you
know you can get digital content you get
articles online relatively free as long
as you are right with with you know
having an ad blocker on but what they've
done is actually moved to experiences
they have The New Yorker festival
every year where they have stages we can
hear from and ask questions to your
favorite podcast host so you're fighters
and they'll have different ways which
you can interact with the platform in a
direct way and we see this in the music
industry where the only way musicians
can make music is is through concerts
and so you have this huge resurgence in
now musicians actually stepping up their
game in massive plays in terms of
actually providing an incredible moment
to moment experiences and lights and
with people and then coming out and
storytelling and all of these amazing
things which you just can't commodify in
the digital space so I think that's
that's one way I hope and again it's
very Kovach contingent this is one way
in which marketing will go the digital
world is always going to be there that's
make plenty of money in the digital
space but these are gonna be commodified
products and really where people are
gonna differentiate is providing these
incredible moment to moment conscious
experiences it just can't be commodified
in the same way that's super cool I have
to say it sounds like that experiential
overwhelming sensation solution is
almost like the antithesis of the
convenience era that we found ourselves
in right yeah everything so much more
easy you can deliver Roo a five-star
meal to your house while you watch
Amazon Prime and then you get an uber to
the you know we what we workstation and
do all this sort of stuff you have all
of these things that are making life
easier and easier and then almost as a
consumer you want a signal from the
things that you're purchasing that this
wasn't easy you know where's the costly
signaling where's the effortful
signaling that's coming in here that's
what I want and you totally right I keep
talking about this dot dot in London
which is the most advanced virtual
reality experience on the planet at the
moment Jeff Wayne's War of the Worlds in
AR VR and holographic projection with
real-life actors and fire and all sorts
of other stuff and I will never forget
that I'll never ever forget it was a
terrible date I actually went with a
chick and and like it was a perfect date
to go with the chick though because for
two hours we didn't have to speak to
each other so in one way it was a
fantastic date and in another way
there's a complete catastrophe but um
you know I won't forget that and the
same you see Coldplay
waves of light up wristbands going
across so you see like pink Pink's like
in a 40s now flying upside down whizzing
around stadiums stuff like that Travis
Barker upside-down drumming you know all
this sort of thing you are right this
the the stepping up of this experience
and what we said today some of the
things that it hits on intensity novelty
the violation of expectation all of that
thing is going to further embed the
memories in your mind you're gonna have
this connection with the brand you know
and then if Budweiser comes out and
sponsors blink-182 or you know Motorola
do a tie-in with pink or whatever is
that's the opportunity for brands there
is to harness like real influence real
genuine goodwill as opposed to
weaponizing it with just psychological
tricks because our amygdala hasn't been
able to catch up yet so guys honestly I
this will be up there with one of the
longest podcasts I think that I've ever
done and I could keep going I honestly
could so um blindsight the mostly hidden
ways marketing reshapes our brain when
is it out because I've just got an
advanced review copy that says may
when's it out it a couple or we tell you
about the book I just want to say Chris
thank you ma'am
you play a very pivotal role in this
whole thing Matt and I are so passionate
about this stuff but we wouldn't be able
to share this stuff with you if it
didn't have people like you who
genuinely gave a [ __ ] about this stuff
and made it because you're you really
are important part of the process man
you are the vessel of information we
create the information we hope it gets
caught up so first of all thank you so
much and you've done it in a way we
studied your podcast man we looked at we
saw you have Paul bloom on we freaking
love problems you know you got an ear
out you had some of these rock star guys
that we look up to you had them on here
no no man you guys are one of them now
you're in with the rock stars rolling at
the big boys now
so no so thank you for owning that man
you're you're you're doing something
really special here and I really hope
you get a lot of success out of this
this is not easy work thank you and we
appreciate that and secondly thank you
for putting us on goes without saying
one thing though just like a total
moment were nobility we don't we didn't
write this book for money first time
authors don't make [ __ ] that's the
honest dirty truth about publishing
we weren't know about we're not
you know if Tonya decided to row to
write a blog in the first time waffle
yeah he'd make a lot of money
we are simply passionate neuroscience
and marketing geeks who found a message
that we wanted to desperately share with
the world and that is how we put in the
grueling intense hours it takes for two
people to think as one and write this
book so this is if nothing else it's
been a massive labor of love and to hear
you tell us that you loved it so much it
means the world to us man so we we do it
so you know like the listeners look what
we covered so far
Christa's list is so much longer than we
covered the book is so much longer than
we cover there's so much other [ __ ] to
talk about but ultimately look buy the
book or don't buy the book the blog is
free it's all there for you we really
just want this to go out there so the
average person knows a little bit more
about this stuff just like we know a
little bit more about user experience so
Chris thank you for being the person who
sort of helps us disseminate this info
man I couldn't be couldn't be more happy
honestly this aligns perfectly with the
things I'm interested in so what's the
tell us what the blog is where can we
get the book where once about all that
stuff
book will be on Amazon and any other any
other major book retailer so if your
anti Amazon that's fine it's on Amazon
it comes out May 19th the the Kindle
version the digital version may 19th
globally otherwise it's sort of
staggered depending on kovat and
delivery situation locally so the
official date is May 19th oh I'll make
sure I'll make sure that this goes out
just after May 19th and I'll make sure
that we schedule this to go just after
that soil trying I'll try and line it
open what about the blow what's the
what's the blood a blog the blog is
popped narrow like pop psych pop neuro
comm yep and completely free come come
hang out with us we talk about Korean
pop music and neuroscience and Kanye and
neuroscience and all kinds of weird
stuff plus nerve plants so it's it's a
bite-sized version of the book so please
check us out that's awesome what about
following you guys online my prince
where can we find you online you guys on
Twitter or anything
yes I'm it Matt Johnson is me and yes
mom I'm on Twitter as Prince guman 24
eight and if none of those are too hard
to remember top Neuros on odds on
Twitter as well just at pop nur
and and we're on that as long I'll make
a full rundown of everything so the link
to the book the link to the blog the
link to Martin Prince and pop new rose
Twitter will be in the show notes below
oh we made it that was so good
for the listeners that are still with us
I really hope that you enjoyed it that's
absolutely fantastic boys you need to do
you need to do blindsight too so I'm
gonna I'm gonna send this I'm gonna send
the recommendation I've already told
Richard chaton that he needs to get on
it the author of the choice Factory and
I'm gonna be sending it to Rory
Sutherland as well the guy that wrote
alchemy
Rory's a German TV episode episode 49 I
think on this podcast he just blew me
away so um don't buy it if ladies and
gentlemen if you're interested in in
marketing and behavioral economics and
all that interesting stuff all the
things we've gone through today go
hassle the guys online you know what to
do if you enjoyed the episode like share
subscribe give me a message let me know
what you thought this has been so so
cool today and I could keep going but I
really need the bathroom now so
gentlemen thank you so much for your
time Prince give the dog a kiss for me
please
my guys thank you truth
[Music]